in 2009 in August my office whether to
major scandals the first was the arrests
trying and conviction in subsequent
incarceration of Detroit's very popular
mayor the second caused the Detroit
Police Department crime lab to be closed
I thought nothing else could go wrong
and then the phone rang it was the
deputy chief of my Special Victims Unit
who was breathless on the other end of
the line he said boss you are never
going to believe what I just saw I had a
sinking feeling in the pit of my stomach
because I knew instinctively the Detroit
was getting ready to suffer its third
major scandal in just over one year he
told me that he had just visited what he
thought was an abandoned warehouse where
the Detroit Police Department was doing
evidence inside were 11341 abandoned
untested rape kits some of them went
back to the 1980s and some of them now
are over 40 years old
these kits were spilling out of large
black garbage bags and empty oil drums
each kit represented a victim mostly a
female that has suffered a violent
sexual assault each of them voluntarily
endured an hours-long rape kit process
with the hopes that the results of that
they would find their perpetrator and
unbeknownst to all of them all 11341
those kits were never tested
I cannot even begin to describe - oh and
by the way before I move on in the
interim of those 40 years those
perpetrators were allowed to continue to
offend with impunity I cannot tell you
or describe to you how outraged mad and
angry that I was I myself was a victim
of sexual assault
back when many decades ago when I was in
law school I also am the mother of three
girls a 21 year old and nine year old
twins I was even more horrified to learn
if that could be more horrified that the
oldest of those kits one of the oldest
of those kits belong to an eight year
old girl I'm gonna tell you her story
but I'm going to call her Natasha
On January 2nd 1990 Natasha was at home
and a man knocked on her door
this man was familiar with her
neighborhood and was familiar with the
comings and goings of her family but
Natasha did not know him he told her
that her grandmother the only mother
that she had ever known had been in a
terrible accident and was laying on a
couch in his house calling for her
terrified that Natasha was going to lose
her grandmother she went with him but of
course we all know her grandmother was
not there once he had isolated Natasha
who was 8 years old he began to rape her
violently he raped her with his mouth
his fingers and his penis and he even
forced his penis into her mouth when he
was done he ordered Natasha to get
dressed he got dressed himself and he
put a blindfold across her head and
walked her to a factory area on the edge
of the neighborhood he asked her if she
knew how to remove the blindfold and
asked her she knew how to get home from
there and when she indicated that she
did he let her go and he walked off
Natasha's rape was reported immediately
and a rape kit was done now the rape kit
process terrifies and try
izes adult women can you imagine what it
was like for a little second grader who
still wore pigtails and still believe in
Santa Claus going through this exam
Natasha's kit sat on the shelf in an
abandoned warehouse for 26 years
Pamela 19 years old
i'ma call her Pamela that's not a real
name nineteen years old was walking down
the street after she had come from
visiting her boyfriend she was grabbed
from behind and she felt what she
thought was a gun in her side she was
taken to an abandoned house to a bedroom
in that house that was filled with trash
every time she tried to resist he would
hit her about the face and the head he
violently raped her on the floor of that
bedroom that was filled with garbage
when he was done he put on his clothes
he stole her money and he just walked
away
Pamela also reported her rape right away
she also had a rape kit done
unlike natashas her kit sat on the shelf
for 15 years now criminals like that
like people who raped Natasha and Pamela
often leave their DNA at a crime scene
but for a rape victim their body is the
crime scene so many elect to go through
this hours-long rape kit process that
requires every inch an orifice of a
victim's body to be combed swapped and
photographed all right after a violent
sexual assault the reason that most
people do this who have a rape kit is
because they want the forensic
scientists to study that rape kit and
hopefully come up with a genetic profile
that will help identify their
perpetrator once forensic scientist
with this genetic profile they enter it
into CODIS hopefully have a match
CODIS is filled with DNA profiles of
people who were arrested and/or
convicted of certain prescribed offenses
if in fact a profile is made and entered
into CODIS it can help identify a
perpetrator in the matter of minutes
CODIS stands for combined DNA index
system now how did we get here
Detroit had no money it costs at that
time that these kids were found up to
$1500 per kit to have it tested so you
do the math about how much that was
going to cost in addition to that within
four years of these kits being found in
2009 Detroit would be the largest
municipality in the history of the
United States to declare bankruptcy we
didn't know what we were gonna do but
not only that as we began to study and
investigate how this possibly could have
happened we discovered there were other
issues besides besides just financial
ones during the course of these decades
where these kits sat in that warehouse
we discovered there had been multiple
changes of police leadership with
different priorities and different
agendas there was woefully inadequate
training for sex crimes officers in the
police department in general there was
chronically they were understaffed and
they had other resource issues and there
was perpetual victim-blaming
when the these victims came to report
their crimes
that's the rape culture and because of
this blip victim-blaming of someone that
had been violently assaulted some of
these victims were even ridiculed and to
not continue to proceed to proceed with
their case the bottom line is that 11341
rape kits set on that shelf I wanted
transparency I asked myself how in the
world
can we stop this coming from spreading I
don't want to go through all this work
in five ten years down the line figure
we had the same issue at that time
police officers had the sole discretion
about whether and when and if they were
going to submit the rape kits for
testing any rape kit in their
jurisdiction were testing that had to
change we had to take that discretion
away from police officers and pass state
laws to ensure that every rape kit is to
be leased by the victim to law
enforcement is tested immediately I also
knew that there had to be some kind of
system to keep everybody honest and to
keep everybody accountable put in place
where we knew where these rape kits were
at any given time the answer was simple
think about all of the hundreds of
thousands and perhaps millions of
packages that are moved by logistics
company every day they're tress and and
tracked and they're know where they are
at every been intern from the time that
they're stored in the warehouse until
the time that that package arrives on
the purchases purchasers front steps why
couldn't we do that for rape kits
I'd had no desire to reinvent the wheel
so I contacted ups ups within two weeks
two weeks of our first meeting with UPS
they had come up with a major plan where
they were involved all the stakeholders
the police officers the prosecutors the
medical facilities the forensic nurses
the hospitals the lab personnel and the
victim advocates could know where the
rape kits were at any given time they
sent a team of experts out and family
detroit-area talked to all the
stakeholders and developed a plan and
studied the life of a rape kit from the
time the rape kit was collected through
to the time that was tested in the lab
and returned to the police personnel
they also developed a web-based portal
that all the stakeholders can look into
and see where any given rape kit was at
any given time ups had the technology
ups knew how to you
that technologies solve our problem and
we didn't we launched a private we we
UPS in the prosecutor's office launched
this pilot program in Detroit and we
started this process on January 28 2015
through to May 25th of 2016 and during
that period of time and remember we're
not dealing with the ones we had found
because they'd already been stored we're
dealing with any new kit that came in as
of January the 28th 2015
and we knew where that rape kit was for
the 16 months of this project we didn't
lose a single rape kit not a single one
we knew where they are
[Applause]
this project went on until the state of
Michigan the elected officials in the
state and state government took notice
of everything that UPS was doing and
everything that my office was doing and
they decided that they were going to use
state funds to develop a statewide
tracking system not in just Detroit but
statewide tracking system hopefully that
system will be up and running soon but I
loved working with UPS I loved their
innovation I love how fast that they
worked I love their unorthodox approach
to ideas to solve everyday common
problem that whose solutions shouldn't
be that simple that should be simple so
after working with them I knew they even
with one company working on one issue
the progress that could be made we've
been at this now for nine years and it
was nine years ago that we rescued those
rape kits from the warehouse that
warehouse has since been torn down but
all of the kits have either been tested
or in final stages of being tested we
still have a lot of work to do in terms
of investigation and prosecution of
those cases but our rape kit issue in
terms of testing is done as of June 28th
2018 our CODIS has have showed us and
identified 2,600 suspects we have
identified 861 serial rapists just
within this project
that means 861 potential defendants that
have raped within the project two or
more times and 50 to 75 of them have
raped 10 to 15 times a piece in one city
in one state also the CODIS results that
we have have tentacles to crime scenes
have linkages in 40 states in the United
States 40 of the 50 states have
to our crime testing of these rape kits
from Alaska to Florida and from Maine to
the most seven parts of California a sea
to shining sea string of CODIS hits
natasha is now 36 years old when she
heard about the work that we were doing
with the rape kits she contacted my
office the Wayne County Prosecutor's
Office her kit was eventually tested in
an identified Paul Warwick in the
interim Paul Warwick had raped two more
women one in the state of Colorado Pau
Warwick is now serving a sentence in the
Michigan Department of Corrections in
prison of 15 to 40 years
[Applause]
[Music]
Emilie's kit was also tested and her kit
led to the identification her coat
estate on her kit led to the
identification of bernard peterson in
the interim bernard Peterson raped ten
more women each of those women had a
rape kit done in each of those women's
rape kits set on the shelf next to
Pamela's for varying number of years
Bernard Peterson is now serving a
sentence in the Michigan Department of
Corrections concurrently that means at
the same time of 60 to 90 years and 90
years to 125 years for the rapes that he
committed
we still have a lot of work to be done
and we desperately need the help of
private private sector we need the help
of the tech industry to help us develop
not help us we want them to develop
information management systems too so we
can all talk to each other and stop
these perpetrators from raping and
maiming and killing with impunity we
also need help help from those of you
with marketing and advertisement
backgrounds we need you to desperately
we need you to develop campaigns for our
children and other people to listen to
so we can stop the culture change the
culture of rape victims refusing to up
they're too afraid to come forward
because of what may happen to them UPS
was one company as I said they helped us
with their innovation and they
revolutionized the way that we can track
rape kits every single aspect of our
lives is tracked every like every mood
shopping history browsing history
reading history our entire web history
is trapped these days what if we could
track the activities in the comings and
goings of criminals who commit crimes
just like people track every aspect of
our lives in 2015
the Obama White House and the US
Department of drugs trust justice put
the number of untested abandoned rape
kits at 400,000 across this country
400,000 that's a national pandemic we
know where a lot of those kids are our
testing showed that women were raped
waiting in their cars waiting for
friends on the way to work on their way
from work at gas stations at shopping
malls and even one of the first cases
that we did when these rape kits were
test starting to be tested was a man who
came into the window and got into the
bed and raped a woman who was in bed
with her two children he raped her while
he was in bed with her two children
every time I look at a rape victim that
comes into my office because their case
is being called or they want they're
being interviewed by the prosecutor
they're being prepped for case I look
into their eyes and I think to myself
they didn't have to be one of the ones
that was raped they didn't have to be
one of those victims and maybe they
would not have been if these rape kits
have been tested timely how many more
Pamela's are in this world
how many more natashas are in this world
we may never know but what I do know is
that you have the technology you know
how to use it and you can help us solve
the problem of rape it's being being
stockpiled thank you
[Music]
[Applause]